[Music]
all right and we are live
I love podcast Lords of gaming that met
with some legendary guests in the realm
of YouTube we have a lady Lauren side
and Lord Bobby how are we doing so
absolute pleasure first of all for you
guys that talk with us talk with us in
the realm we like to celebrate our
content creators see what their journey
was like how it was so well let's start
from the very beginning this is a very
unique that having obviously husband and
co-creator and wife could create a kind
of a channel so let's start with the
journey in the beginning like what was
it like to get church shadow started
what was the initial vision and
foundation of the channel yeah sure so I
actually went to college for video
production and TV production so I was
super into video and used to I think
both of us actually used to film like
our friends and very stupid stuff so I
had a youtube channel like back in 2007
I think I regret not continuing it in
college I was kind of like go to college
like kind of forget about this and then
I graduated from college got a job like
office work super boring and on the side
I started noticing that people were
playing games on YouTube now because
that was not a thing when I first
started there's not many women that do
this so I was like maybe I could do it
for fun so it's never like I didn't even
know people made money from it at that
point still cuz back when I knew YouTube
you didn't make money on it so I started
doing that I was like just to hone my
like editing skills and all that stuff
for fun and it just kept growing and
people resonate it resonated with people
because it was like a demographic that
wasn't there just yet and then it kept
growing and eventually it started like
making more income than our actual jobs
at one point I couldn't keep up I wanted
to I actually worked in like
professional sports which was a really
cool job oh very cool yeah
and I didn't want to leave that job just
yet so then my husband was not happy
with his job at the time the Wall Street
you see her kind of bubbling real
quickly I was like what was your
reaction to seeing the success initially
that she was having it was just chipping
away and I was studying late to get my
Wall Street s it was it was awesome
because it was a really yeah one of my
biggest advice whenever people asked him
like just go with what you have like I
literally was filming audio from my
phone that I already had we we had like
an old iMac that's terrible for gaming
like if you watch my old videos they're
super laggy but it's like kept going
through I was like yeah this is fine
it's fine like yeah so it's are you
saying at that point you kind of just
like decided hey we're gonna cut these
real jobs we're gonna kind of push yeah
so he was super unhappy and I said hey
let me finish out my job I have like -
my boss was under contract because it
was like professional sports I was like
once he's gone I don't feel a need to
stay anymore so if you can cover the
backend stuff so I can just come film
and then you can take care of the
business until I'm done that would be
great so he put his notice in for his
job and literally a week after he put
his notice in my boss got let go and I
lost my job Wow
okay yeah this is this is a Bowman yeah
we don't want to go so at that moment
it's real now you know how are you now
enduring during that period like that
exact moment
we actually had our first anniversary
trip scheduled for Ireland and it was
like we had budgeted for whatever we're
like in Ireland and that was the first
time we realized we were like full time
we were like hopefully this like at
least we said we tried and then
everything just doubled from there so
like because I was putting 50% into
YouTube then I went to do it a hundred
and luckily it just when you kind of did
that your family is kind of were they
were very receptive to do they
understand it or is it kind of just like
you know that the regular parents
reaction married and then they just me
letting them know exactly it wasn't like
anything crazy my question specific
though is when you guys explain that it
was YouTube we were doing did you get
pushback like understand why like they
like they they were okay they're his
parents are pretty like open like open
about like trying new things and stuff
my mom's very like she wanted me to be a
teacher and like she even like a year
into it and we were doing pretty well at
that point like she still was like oh do
you think like Bobbi I'll at least get a
job - like supplement it was like yeah
but he doesn't he like brings more value
not working a regular job like it was
hard to explain
now they fully get it like they better
we go to like Disney World with them and
I'm getting like stopped constantly I
know they understand now
oh it's different it's different take
the VIP like
to seeing her mom react to that she's
now they literally any time we go out
there like if we talk to somebody they
like oh did you watch YouTube I'm like
stop completely invested now they were
worried but they weren't like to like
don't do this we're gonna like cut ties
with you yeah they weren't too bad they
they know we're pretty smart so we
wouldn't just be like I know we watched
a handful of the videos there's a lot of
editing in that like how long do you
guys take for between like you know
recording on Episode two cutting it to
publishing it out do you guys have a set
time frame or do you guys just kind of
make it roll or different the more
highly edited hands-on ones so I have a
couple so Bobby's my main editor and so
he'll be like the main if I have a
really hands-on video that needs a lot
to edit or I don't know exactly what I
want with it like we'll work on it
together like he'll edit the whole thing
and then like I'll get to watch it and
be like maybe this usually that was my
goal was one video every day for a year
and I did it and then right then I was
like okay I'm gonna take a break for a
week that was like the first time ever
one video every day for a year
yeah that's like I want to talk about
the burnout for example as a content
creator obviously you know the intensity
of the rigorous schedule that you're
doing you know how do you balance it so
that it's still fun because your child a
lot of it's based on humor a lot of it
is being funny and and projecting your
personality like how do you how are you
able to maintain that level where it's
like okay there's like a job where I'm
just like you know I don't have the
energy to do it like and I can kind of
feel it coming on so I'll try to
backtrack but sometimes there's no
helping it like I'm traveling or there's
like somebody like there's a death in
the family I've been working through
like deaths in the family like getting
like serious illnesses me just not
having a good day so if I am having a
good day I try to like pep that up and
work as much as I possibly can because
I'm like I don't know if this is gonna
be gone tomorrow so so then how do you
how do you figure out what like content
you're gonna make yeah so reading back
to like what our process is like so the
more highly produced video some of those
take like an hour or an hour so let's
take a day so like like my we started
doing like true and true and couples
pranks that did really good those take
an entire day to film like recreating
tick-tocks take an entire day to film
like anything that's a mix of like
either gaming or digital and real life
those taking all day to film so I have
to like schedule it out but literally on
Sundays I sit down and I schedule my
entire week out but I kind of give
myself a day so I'll plan to do most of
my work Monday Tuesday Wednesday cuz I
have to get it to my either other
editors or Bobby to edit in time for the
weekend drops so but I'll give myself a
day so like it'll be like a flex day so
if Monday I'm waking up and I'm feeling
crappy or something happened or it's
like out of my control I have that flex
day I mean sometimes it doesn't work out
I'll have my two or three days a little
snowball and yeah but so it can range
like if I do gaming videos they're more
so an hour to two hours of filming
depending what kind of game and then
editing takes we learn from you and I
was noticing my my mind was moving fast
in my hands good be creative so I got
really good at just editing real quick
so now I first pass
flowers and then I come back and you
know add in traffic yeah it's just I've
gotten there's something that I picked
up real quick absolutely now what is
specifically about the content creation
process from a standpoint of what were
some of the things you created there
maybe initially like I don't know if
this is gonna work
or your viewers would be receptive to it
and you like I cannot believe this is
doing what it's doing like people are
loving this like any specific moments
like that stabs now and they're always
like that video like I don't even know
where you thought of that whenever I
find a video idea that I'm like nobody
else has done this I'm gonna do it even
though it's written one was like I built
myself as a house to battle my inner
demons in and it was different versions
of myself as the same as putting them in
a house that looked like me switch was
creepy and then like battling to see
which personality was like the best so
and that did really good I said this is
either gonna bomb or do great really
great
but the Sims when I blew up with that
that was my first like kind of rise yeah
because I was like everybody's playing
The Sims and this like cutesy like lay
me to family mine was like oh five
nights at Freddy's is a is a popular
game I'm gonna put that in The Sims even
though like you can't make those
characters like people that look like
these animatronics is always creepy and
like people loved it they were like this
is so ridiculous it's like so I kind of
ran with that so now it's just like
taking games and making them predict do
you end up um like taking like
suggestions from like your social media
like people talking to you going hey
what do you do you think this would be
funny do you think that's funny or do
you just keep it in-house like you guys
sit down at the dinner table essentially
they go I think I have an idea for a
pitch it's probably a mix of
and I did I listen to a podcast once
actually that like PewDiePie was on and
he said he said he always half listen to
his audience cuz his audience only half
understands what's what's gonna work
right so like so I always took that I'm
like okay like half my okay so like
they'll give me a suggestion and every
now and then I'll be like that's not
gonna work or I won't enjoy that so
we're not gonna do it but sometimes
they've had some really good ideas
especially what series like that
components of it they like they know
what they want to watch so as long as I
think it will fit or I kind of know the
trends and okay that yeah that works
like that's a great idea
but then we also have sessions were all
like he's skimming through YouTube and
I'm like I'll show him something I'm
like oh my god what if I did this by
this one of the funny parts of me is
like direct is so how many how many of
you are working together as a team just
the two of you is it multiple or how
many people totally near like the main
part of the team is bobbi and I I also
have two other like kind of Swing
editors because he travels so much with
me I need like you so they they'll help
with a lot of the the more not simpler
edits but things that I can flat-out be
like this is what I want right go with
it and they're great too and then I have
one like virtual assistant that helps
with like my email inboxes ridiculous
now and like all that back-end stuff but
it's really just like I have a lot of
friends that were at my level or less
and got offices and a bunch of staff and
stuff but I know myself like to help
with my burnout and stress and stuff I
can't have that all on my shoulders so
like at one point I wanted to like hire
friends and family and all this stuff
but at the end of the day I'm like I
still want so much control over my
that's my hardest it was even hard to
get editors for the first time your baby
yeah it's like you know so much respect
for it that you know it's a level of
detail and intricacy that you want to
take with it is that is what's the
mindset I think it's that I want it to
always be I don't want to be like I know
a lot of people that show up and they're
literally show up they're the face they
film and they leave and like everything
else is up to their team but then you
kind of like lose a part like I feel
like the editing adds comedy to it the
title and idea like there's people who
like have idea thinkers like I don't
even have that like I just sit that's
where most of my time goes is probably
just idea thinking as good or better
than me I would do it listen I
definitely list edit that's a big day
because I get it it's your baby your
vision and unless someone taps into
those emotional notes that you resonate
with stuff like if we don't care but
like they're never gonna care just like
you working for anybody else
this isn't changing because I'm letting
someone else's hands touch it and even
when I watch it that's why product
production value like we've upped our
production equipment but we never go too
far that it feels too polished because I
feel like our audience likes the fact
that we're pretty like not polished and
like they feel like they're our friends
and come talk to us like that yeah I
want to ask from starting content
creator right you know obviously you
guys been through the grind you know you
get cheap santevia success you're still
growing and what advice would you get to
people on the way up you know that that
really may have good ideas but you know
may get frustrated they're not getting
to where they want to get and stuff like
that what advice would you say to those
people who are really trying to come up
in YouTube as a content
you try to think of something that
hasn't been said my advice but I like to
see people do is try everything because
you never know what you're gonna find
your nation never know what's gonna
bring out your best creativity so you
might you know be a big fan of the Sims
or be you don't know oh maybe I'll go
play this other game then I've never
played before and my reactions to it are
great so don't lock yourself down the
biggest thing or anytime somebody I know
people now that like know what I do and
they're like I want to start a YouTube
channel okay that's so he's like yeah
yeah and then like weeks will go by yeah
I'm still working on my first like
editing my first video I was like weeks
later and they're like I just want it to
be perfect I'm like that's like the
biggest hold up I feel like is people
just starting like they have such a
problem just just started because
they're worried they're gonna look
stupid it's not gonna be exactly as we
pictured but it's not regardless like
you're gonna be awkward it's not gonna
be what you thought but that's why I
always say I leave my first videos ever
up nice so embarrassing to watch
when I leave them up because I'm like I
want people to see that like you don't
start like where I'm at exactly it's it
took so long before you start noticing
my demeanor changes on camera I was so
like stiff and so so what what video
would you say then ended up kind of like
making well other than you know your
transition for your job who was this was
assumes what kind of like push you like
your video going yeah okay we can
definitely do this
I think the first like really viral
video that I got like The Sims yeah oh
yeah she did like a 24 hour living as a
sin like challenge where she did exactly
what her city we watched everybody
else's videos was like they definitely
edited this like they definitely didn't
do this for 24 hours like I think one
person maybe did that I thought they did
I said I'm gonna actually do it cuz you
should be able to tell that I did it and
you could like at the end of the video I
like drained it was the
worse day but like that's my most viewed
video people love that so then I did
like eating like a sim painting like I
said like we just kept going with that
that did really good and then like I
also started to when before tick tock
became big when people were like making
fun of it yeah I was like oh my god I
got to get on this and I did like
recreating them and that book I remember
checking my phone we were like going out
to dinner and I was like how many I got
this many views in an hour like this is
insane and that was right around the
time we started doing it full time to
the Lord over here the the co-creator
Cole co-founder heard you are a destiny
band well you know the iron Lords were
built the foundation was off of destiny
but so we still plan is it any chance to
get you in the realm as far as destiny
back into the game all you kind of
retired from that life is like another
marriage you know this is going to sound
like he's going through it and getting
frustrated with my friends
and then we came back actually wet and
completed it with another person just
because he was a sense of accomplishment
is amazing I will say this do we go for
the detention but I will say it's one of
those things that when you experience a
rain for the first time like you like
you were saying in a sense of you have a
bond with that person that process like
your brother you went through we Vietnam
with him like it's it's serious so so
you guys just exclusively on YouTube
where are you guys using like you said
another streamer do you guys using
twitch or mixer or something else twitch
twitch I'm trying to turn into like my
like games that my audience doesn't
normally like but I like games like
teams that like my audience wouldn't
naturally gravitate to I played like old
Nintendo games on there like that's it's
for me like YouTube's for them now are
you saying that you're using that kind
of as your downtime is your enjoyment
time we tried to do it as part of the
business but like I can't keep up with
it with the schedule I already have so
and like being on Twitch you have to
have a schedule and we I watch people
all the time on it but like me
personally I can't keep up with it so
it's more of like a leisurely thing like
I want to play this game but I can't
want to talk to people especially the
new game drops or I have questions then
I'll play it and I have like my set
smaller group of fanbase that's there
that doesn't care what I play and then
we'll hang out so it's fun for that yeah
that's pretty awesome
the final question would ask as far as
joint things together early in a channel
have you guys collaborate together on
camera maybe maybe some stuff as a
husband
do war the channel we've been starting
to like if I have a game that I think
would be fun with another person like we
just played a couples break up game
interesting yeah okay and then like
recently I rechecked it was like oh wait
this is doing good now so like we bounce
off each other this is absolutely
awesome
just to hear the journey to hear you
guys story you know as a consecrate this
kind of stuff in boulders us to see you
know the success stories and just the
chemistry you guys have unique dynamic
because technically it also works you're
able to do you know what you do and
again this is a tremendous tremendous
bigness see so any last words to your
fans your base like that's been the
three main eating healthy and like
taking care of yourself because I love
that you said that because you had to
have that balance physically taking care
of yourself and I love that you said
also the aspect of the twitch as most as
much as you have to serve your community
we get it love the balance and absolute
pleasure to have you two in the world
lady Lord Lord Bobby of the Destiny clan
[Laughter]
absolute pleasure PD this is great iron
law podcast Lords of gaming dotnet we
are signing out figs
[Music]